hallo mein name ist luca und ich spiele
gerne kleine blöde spiele deswegen
spielen wir heute das spiel pixo das ist
ein spiel wo wir treffen müssen deshalb
ich auf jeden fall schon mal richtig
gemacht gerade da steht ab und desto
öfter ich treppe desto öfter kann ich
halt hierdurch und dieses level
verändern sich das heißt ich muss das
ist unfassbar schwer grad gewesen ach so
ok ist ja nicht so dass es schon genug
wäre wenn die teile sich von oben nach
unten bewegen packen die einfache
drehende blöcke rein ich glaube dieses
video heute wird nicht lang sowie das
bisher schon funktioniert hat also tempo
auch so ich dachte schon ich mit guter
versuch luca aber wie start natürlich
einen zweiten versuch denn jetzt da ich
da auf einmal gerade nach oben gezogen
worden
ok man high schools 56 den habe ich
gerade aufgestellt daran fehlt ihr das
der spiel vorher noch kein mal gespielt
habe sondern im app store angesehen habe
wir müssen das doch irgendwie staffeln
es kann doch nicht dass wir irgendwie
dann jetzt okay da ist der fall das
heißt wir sind jetzt oben das heißt
jetzt heftig hier lang
das war schon mal ganz nah am high
school war nicht mehr 47 also jetzt das
ist doch nicht nur das sieht doch
bestimmt nur schwer aus aber geht sonst
eigentlich klar
zwei hinter dem highscore alter das ist
ja auch etwas nicht genug dass die teile
da schon mega eng sind die bewegen sich
halt auch noch so warte jetzt jetzt
meine chance ich bin über reiskorn 60
jetzt jetzt jetzt das ist so ein
bisschen scheiße aber erinnert mich ein
bisschen an jump league oder wie heißt
dieser modus in minecraft wo man so
immer die gleichen
okay da war ein anderer teil dieser
modus wo man auch so viel springen muss
allerdings nicht die passagen immer
verändern weil hier ist das auch so und
zwar gibt's halt teilweise wirklich die
passage habe ich alles schon gesehen
hier die hier mit dir wo die dinge
aufeinander zugehen gab schon dann gab
es auch dass hier schon mit den mit
das gab's jetzt noch nicht
beispielsweise den gewiss dass ich meine
das ist diese einem modus wo immer so
ganz viele unterschiedliche passagen
kommen und man sich quasi items sammelt
euch das fahrrad neue ice gonna man
sammelt sich da quasi altem um dann
später irgendwie im kampf bessere items
als der andere und die passagen sind
halt immer gleich und das ist halt hier
genau der gleiche fall was auch gleich
ist ich kann beides nicht
hier ist es so ok die dinge gehen
auseinander danke das hat mir trotzdem
gab nichts gebracht 103 schon mal neue
high score aber da gibt definitiv noch
mehr nur wenn die dinger man mir endlich
mal ein bisschen entgegenkommen würde
nicht immer zusammen gehen würden ich
dachte ich dass ich mit geometrie des
damals ich verlinke euch das video mal
irgendwo wartet wenn ich tot bin zeige
ich euch dabei helfen neue high score
ballast ich lenke euch das video mal
hier oben das war das geometrie des
video da bin ich schon sehr ausgelastet
das war so ähnlich allerdings ist dieses
spiel tatsächlich noch schwerer als
german träsch wurde ich ja echt sagen
muss dass ich schon froh bin dass ich
ein highscore habe der sich mit 100
davor sah aussprechen lässt und 225 da
bin ich ja schon froh drauf also ich
dachte hätte echt beginn dieses videos
gedacht so okay wenn ich über 50 komme
bin ich froh so in etwa aber es wird
auch irgendwie schwer
wie kommst du falls ob jetzt viel
schwierigere passagen kommt schaut euch
das mal an das ist doch nicht wahr das
ist auch einfach nur süß von dem spiel
ich weiß doch nie was ich dabei
kommentieren soll das ist ja einfach nur
scheiße und schwer doch wahrscheinlich
bin ich da genau gegen gekommen du arsch
blödmann ok luca da ist ein pfeil
das kriegt doch jetzt das ist die
schwierigste passage von allem wenn
dieser scheiß fall kommt wir sind noch
dran wir sind noch dran wir sind noch am
limit
wir sind natürlich noch nicht am limit
aber jetzt auch schon immer näher daran
weil es immer gott verdammt schwieriger
wird so jetzt kommen wir dieser scheiß
grüne passage da hüpfe ich natürlich
einfach durch als wär's nicht ecke
natürlich an dass man natürlich klar
soll das hier ist nicht allzu schwer da
kommen immer die dinge runtergefahren da
kann man sich ganz gut immer bei
konzentrieren
ich sage dazu nichts mehr die cer
highscore verdächtig aus wir sind schon
bei der 100 100 da ist der neue high
score hunger ok elf mehr als der
highschool das war schon mal ganz nice
ok meine lieblings passage war gerade
die rote
die blaue findig geht ist scheiße da
kann sich halt auf die passagen
einstellen also man weiß genau wann komm
schon
nur einmal mehr als 125 136 und das
könnte jetzt eventuell sogar der fall
sein 100 130 und hier kommen über 144
van bett und nicht unten
dieses ziel ist dementsprechend die 144
zu knacken
das wird sich aber als gar nicht mehr so
leicht raus stellen weil jetzt ist schon
wieder in eine andere richtung
ich hasse dieses spiel es ist nicht
möglich irgendwas okay wir machen jetzt
mal was wenn jemand von euch in diesem
spiel 1000 schafft und mir zu den video
days sein handy mitbringt um ihr zeigen
kann dass da 1000 draufsteht
dann mache ich irgendwas und keine
ahnung was ich dann mache es kriegt
keiner von euch hin als auf einer 1000
schafft mein gott friends 159 wie just
got no hi speed racer jetzt hier noch
mal stellt sich das sind alles meine
lieblings passagen die sich einfach
durch schöpfen muss ich nichts
gott verdammt bewegt oder auch hier
beispiel 96 da bin ich geboren hier bin
ich noch kein mal an dem ersten dinge
überhaupt vorbeigekommen es ist ja so
verdammt schwer
hier das ist einfach das gleiche nun
großer komme ich auch immer nicht durch
so haben wir jetzt hier was genau hier
bewegt sich auch wieder irgendwas so
dass es am ende wieder so ganz genau
wahrscheinlich stürzt sich da auch
wieder abbauen
okay das geht noch klar jetzt hier
kommen wieder die teile hochgefahren
schon wieder ein richtiges level gewesen
ich glaub man wird irgendwann behindert
von der scheiße ich glaube irgendwann
werden man mit den augen dann hat man
irgendwann sonne
ich gebe es auf ein letzter versuch
immer diese scheiss letzte versuch 48